Banks and the financial system are back
in our headlines and not for the right
reasons raising a question how worried
should we be getting here's your
five-point guide to this roller coaster
[Music]
perhaps the best place to start is with
interest rates you probably notice
they're going up as central banks trying
to Bear Down on inflation which is also
going up and whenever interest rates
rise it tends to cause consequences
sometimes chain reactions sometimes
malfunctions that run through the entire
Financial system
[Music]
that brings us to Silicon Valley bank
now Silicon Valley Bank was like the
past tense there slightly odd Bank it
didn't deal with normal customers like
you or me but with tech firms these
Founders they got lots of money in for
Venture Capital firms and they put it
into their Accounts at Silicon Valley
bank and then the bank needed to work
out where to put that money in in their
case they put it mostly into a type of
bond which turned out to go down in
value when interest rates went up you
see the connection there the second
issue was that all of those depositors
they had so much money in their accounts
and only so much of that is protected
250 000 in the US 85 000 pounds in the
UK that they've realized if there was a
problem at the bank and they thought
there was going to be a problem they
needed to get that money out fast and
that began a bank run
foreign
s never end well that was certainly the
case for Silicon Valley Bank the UK arm
was sold off to HSBC for the princely
sum of one pound the American arm it's
slightly more complicated the federal
authorities stepped in and said we are
going to ensure that all depositors can
have all of their deposits insured in
other words you're not going to lose
anything over 250 000 that was
effectively bailing out a lot of wealthy
investors but it wasn't quite like the
bailouts that we saw in 2008 and the
other issue was it raised all sorts of
questions about other Banks how about
small banks in MidWest America are they
going to be protected as well no one
knew and so people started gradually to
take money out of those smaller Banks
and put it into the big ones causing
problems throughout America
[Music]
so that's Silicon Valley Bank and it's
worth just saying there were other banks
in America which got into trouble at the
same time and following all of that
people were looking around working out
who the next one to four might be which
was the weakest bank one with a history
of trouble turned out that was Swiss
Bank Credit Suisse that got into trouble
through its share price fall enormously
and was taken over in a shotgun wedding
by UBS
but here's the thing this rescue Force
takeover whatever you want to call it
had a few issues as well because the way
it worked was that certain people who
owned bonds a particular type of bonding
credit Suites were wiped out overnight
and they thought they shouldn't have and
so now you have a lot of people holding
these same types of bonds across the
banking Cosmos for all over the world
wandering to themselves hang on are
these actually worth any money you see
the issues as with Silicon Valley Bank
the nature of the rescue has raised just
as many questions as it has provided
answers
having said all of that does it feel
like we're facing 2008 another big
financial crisis all over again
I feel quite like it to me famous last
words but the system isn't as rotten as
it was back then what certainly has
happened is people have been reminded
that however big the bank wherever it is
if everyone takes their money out at
once
it's got a big problem